[Music]
hey Outlander fans I'm Liana Galera and
joining me right now is Outlanders
executive producer Matt Roberts Matt
thank you so much for welcoming me into
lolly bra side to have you here how do
you like it I love it so much I feel
like this is now my home away from home
well we set it up just for you so thank
you very much but what I'm excited about
is that we are gonna get to see lolly
Brock a little bit more this year
because quite a bit of season 3 centers
around the home but season one I feel
like was really about establishing Jamie
and Claire's love season 2 is a little
bit about testing it what would you say
is their journey in season 3 is love
really worth fighting for and Jamie and
Claire story is a love story and it will
always continue and that's what binds
them together and it's the things that
come into their life that causes the
problems it's not the love the love's
always there I love that well because
especially some of the fans were saying
that they wish they had had more
romantic moments in season 2 first
season 3 do you want them to really just
fixate as you said on the love between
Jamie and Claire I think seeing how
important that love is to each character
without each other and and that's to me
what shows how much they love each other
that they can't even have a whole life
without the other person and I think we
do a really good job in showing that
they're not whole people without each
other
mm-hmm in season 2 you guys stuck very
closely to the book obviously you had a
little bit of your own interpretations
on it how are you viewing season 3
because so much happens in Voyager that
putting it on screen I feel like could
last hundreds of episodes let alone
however many we're gonna get in season 3
so what is that fine line between
showing what's gonna happen and putting
your own spin on things a lot of its
production based and what we can do the
books are very big and we try to stay as
close to the story as possible we have
to veer off because of how we what
practically we can tell it in a time and
then the space we can do it if we always
go in especially in the writers room we
always say this is the story let's try
to stick with that as close as possible
but it's when we beer off we try to get
back to it as soon as possible
exactly we'll have the the same
essential end game yes
now with season three comes a special
challenge of adding 20 years to all of
our actors what was the biggest
challenge been for you guys and the
writers arm in doing that physically
Dianna doesn't describe them as aged up
that much anyway so I think what we do
is we kind of weather them a little more
and let time their emotions to speak and
they age through their acting more than
physically yeah what is the one thing
that you want Outlander fans to know
before they tune into season three
really the one thing one thing the one
thing you'll be rewarded for your
patience you really will I think this is
gonna be one of our most epic season
it's gonna be big both in scale and in
the amount of raw emotion and love on
the screen I think I think they'll be
rewarded
[Music]
you